[Musica]
io contenta di piazzare qui ringrazio i
ragazzi dell'organizzazione che mi hanno
voluta è il mio primo tempo quindi se
sarà un po' imbranata cercate di
comprenderlo e quando mi hanno Mi hanno
chiamato per venire per venire qui a
parlare del coraggio delle idee mi sono
chiesta perché io e allora sono dovuta
partire lavorando nella comunicazione da
quello che per Ormai per la maggior
parte di noi è il canale comunicativo
più importante che è appunto il nostro
Instagram e a me l'avete già messa
Allora
io mi presento così nella biodistagram
molto male a volte moglie ancora figlia
sempre sorella altalenante amica e si
può ma su un po' imprenditrice
Ovviamente i social ci permettono di
sintetizzare quello che siamo ma questa
deve essere solamente una sintesi in
realtà ognuno di noi è molto molto di
più Per quanto mi riguarda l'auto
rispetto a detto questo è collegato a
una caratteristica che mi ha sempre
diciamo è stata sempre per me è
fondamentale che è il coratto il
coraggio di esprimere quella che sono a
volte può piacere a volte può non
piacere Ma nella comunicazione Secondo
me è fondamentale e quando appunto mi è
stato chiesto di venire qui a parlare
del coraggio delle idee mi sono in
qualche modo chiesta Che cos'è un'idea
un'idea è un pensiero intuitivo e
probabilmente solo tipo su qualcosa che
non abbiamo ancora risolto e idea getta
luce rende Chiara Maria per non per
niente nella fumettistica e l'idea è
rappresentata da una lampadina che si
accende e che si abbiamo idee Ma perché
è così importante o c'è bisogno di così
tanto coraggio per poterle mettere in
pratica in qualsiasi campo se io adesso
vi chiedessi di pensare a un personaggio
dell'economia dell'assenza dello
spettacolo per voi è considerato un
personaggio innovativo ognuno di voi
avrebbe in mente una persona Però allora
sette sei facile immaginarle perché fai
così difficile avere il coraggio delle
proprie idee perché secondo me da sempre
un'idea è quindi un innovazione è un
cambiamento ed
è un caspetto a quello che è consueto e
per poter vivere deve affrontare una
forza equivalente e contraria che ci
blocca e sapete qual è secondo me è la
convenienza
mi converrà fare questo passo mi
converrà avere queste idee se non
funziona e se mi sbaglio e che cosa
dicono di me è meglio lasciar perdere
Queste sono delle domande che ci
facciamo tutti Ecco secondo me il
passaggio successivo importante è quello
di dire chi se ne frega Scusate chi se
ne frega ma questo non si sente Ok
secondo me il coraggio delle idee
specchi e coraggio di essere se stessi
ed in un mondo che è totalmente
omologato l'unicità dell'essere può fare
molta poca un'idea una nostra idea è ciò
che siamo che diventa realtà e noi in
una forma di pensiero e di proiezione
aver paura delle proprie idee e aver
paura di sé e questo è un problema
problema e in qualche modo è un problema
ed è la crosta poi di chi ci comanda e
di chi ci vuole separare invasioni e
ecco perché Ci vuole coraggio Ci vuole
coraggio Perché
avere coraggio delle proprie idee
significa essere unici e questo periodo
storico l'unicità è una delle cose più
difficili da raggiungere Ezra Pound
disse Se un uomo non intende correre
qualche rischio per le sue idee o queste
non valgono nulla o non vale niente lui
io non so se ho avuto delle idee Cali
per poter restare qui in questo momento
a raccontarvi di me Diciamo che
sicuramente aver scelto di fare
imprenditrice che era una società di
casting nel 2005 e in qualche modo è
stata inizialmente una scelta non banale
lavoravo in televisione facevo delle
piccole cose però ho scelto di investire
su di me non per quanto riguardava la
smetta esteriore ma su quello che avevo
da dire quello che poi mi ero laureata
Voi direte Beh è facile per una come te
creare un'impresa e sicuramente non nego
che io sia stata avvantaggiata ma non
basta però avere delle conoscenze che ti
introducono all'interno di un mondo Per
tenere viva la realtà che quest'anno
diventa maggiorenne la via società si
chiama voi
la mia società ti chiama SDN 2005 come
vedete
ha prodotto Questa è una casualità che
abbiamo messo tutti i programmi di Paolo
Bonolis ma in realtà ne abbiamo prodotti
anche molti altri e con la SDN sono
cresciute sotto tutti i punti di vista
ho avuto l'occasione di far crescere uno
staff di ragazzi che abbiano iniziato
giovanissimi e che adesso battano chi 30
chi 35 di 40 anni e quindi questo vuol
dire che lavorano con me da 18 anni e
hanno tutti iniziato da i settori più
facili della produzione televisiva e
molti di essi qua ce n'è uno che fa
l'autore televisivo molti diretti adesso
sono diventati autori televisivi e anche
per produttori e l'azienda è un'azienda
che ti passa sulla creatività Ma che non
deve Mai perdere il contatto con la
realtà e con quelle che sono le
possibilità e questo è un Balance
imprescindibile quando ti produce un
programma sono i microcosmo della
Fantasia è quello della concretezza
devono utilizzare sempre di pari passo e
quindi personalmente sono orgogliosa di
dire che siamo riusciti a realizzare in
questo 18 anni molte molti molti
programmi siamo ora delle società di
gatti che produttori televisivi più
richieste da broadcast vi dicevo prima
tornando indietro ecco qua quindi molto
madre a batte moglie ancora figlia
perché molto madre perché in questo
periodo storico può essere una donna
lavorare avere dei figli e cercare in
tutti i modi di essere presente dalla
famiglia e non è facile
e mi piace raccontare una leggenda che
in qualche modo
sento mia allora la leggo perché
per no Per raccontarvela meglio allora
una leggenda indiana dice che L'Aquila
vive devo mettere L'Aquila
vive fino a 70 anni ma perché ciò possa
accadere intorno ai 40 deve prendere una
decisione molto difficile a questa età i
suoi artigli non riescono più ad
afferrare le prede di cui si nutre il
suo becco si incurva le ali invecchiate
e appesantite puntano contro il petto e
borario come è difficile la fila sono
due alternative lasciati morire o
affrontare un doloroso processo di
Rinnovamento che dura 150 giorni se
decide per la seconda opzione L'aquila
vola Allora in cima alla montagna e si
ritira sul nido inaccessibile qui
comincia a battere il becco sulla parete
fino a staccarlo affrontando con
coraggio il dolore di questa operazione
passate alcune settimane Lei cresce mo
ho becco con questo strappa 1 a 1 il
curante del dolore i vecchi artigli
quanto riescono vi crescono i vari
artigli con questi e con il becco
strappa dal suo corpo tutte le penne
quando
nuove penne La Nuova Aquila si lancia
sifura nel volo del rinnovamento e
ricomincia a vivere per 30 anni Questo
che vuol dire che arrivano dei momenti
della vita in cui è doloroso ma è
necessario cambiare e rinascere
Personalmente io questo percorso di
Rinnovamento l'ho fatto qualche anno
dopo i 40 anni spero di vivere finocchio
più lungo di là però fatto un passaggio
che per me a oggi è stato molto molto
coraggioso negli ultimi due anni sono
passata da dietro le quinte a davanti la
telecamera perché ho fatto l'opinionista
televisiva e devo dirvi per come sono
fatta io è stata una scelta molto
coraggiosa perché ripeto sono una
persona che non ha il non detto che non
ama i compromesso e che quindi con la
mia faccia ho messo tutto quello che
pensavo e tutto quello che reputavo
fosse avesse senso dire delle
desinemente questa cosa mi ha portato
Aspetta eh No Oddio sono davanti mi ha
portato in questo posto
tantissime haters Chi sono gli haters
gli haters sono delle non identità sono
persone politiche qualificate nascoste
che sono comunque abili a colpirti
perché non sanno non hanno la campagna
idea di che cosa voglia dire in secondo
me impegnarsi in qualche cosa E allora
se sei debole possono farti male se non
sei dotato una struttura importante e
forte e non sai consapevoli di te stesso
possono fare davvero davvero molto male
eh Ecco questa per esempio è una
modalità di persone che probabilmente
non hanno avuto il coraggio di dare
importanza alle proprie idee E di
investire su se stessi e pensano che sia
molto più facile e forse anche più molto
più edificante buttare giù chi invece ha
combattuto per tirar fuori il proprio
pensiero rispetto invece a chi è rimasto
lì il fermo e dietro una uno schermo si
diverte a criticare gli E questa
modalità di giudizio è comunque una
modalità molto poco coraggiosa e
personalmente non mi ha mai colpito
tanto perché lo leggo appunto come una
sintomo di un rancore nei confronti di
chi invece ripeto ha provato a farcela
perché presi presume che solamente
perché una persona è benestante Perché
una persona non si vergogna a dimostrare
la propria vita o anche quello che
maggiormente della propria vita può
attirare l'attenzione no Per questo
debba questa persona deve essere
distrutta Personalmente io ho la
serenità che sta per gestire tutto
questo ma penso alle persone soprattutto
donne bambine che invece i bambini che
invece questa forza non ce l'hanno e
allora
io dico anche un'altra cosa e io sono
una mamma sono mamma di tre figli tre
ragazzi e un percorso che ho dovuto fare
è stato quello di fare in due passi
indietro
a livello di socal per cercare di
preservare loro che invece da un punto
di vista sociale sono spesso stati
attaccati Perché le persone volevano
colpire noi e quindi ho cercato in
qualche modo di mediare tra quella che
era la mia grillole provocatoria è una
necessità dei miei figli e quindi ho
fatto parte indietro per loro sono mamma
dicevo
moglie mamma imprenditrice mamma dice
Ragazzi litighiamo con Silvia Davide
Adele sono tre ragazzi molto diversi tra
loro ma chi mi ha insegnato veramente
Che cos'è il coraggio è la mia figlia
più grande che si chiama Silvia Silvia
Alla nascita è stata colpita da un
ipossia Durante un intervento chirurgico
e oggi una ragazza di 20 anni felice che
affronta la vita al giorno dopo giorno
con forza con tutte le necessità che
hanno le ragazze di vent'anni Con le
pretese che hanno le ragazze di
vent'anni Ma che a differenza dei suoi
coetanei lotta ogni giorno per
conquistare parole e movimenti e credo
che la cosa fondamentale
di noi genitori è quella di renderci
conto che in realtà il coraggio bisogna
tirarlo fuori tutti i giorni noi perché
la vera coraggiosa nella nostra famiglia
è lei e
il fratello e la sorella
si muovono semplicemente morti da quella
che è la forza più importante che spesse
volte è collegata al coraggio ed è
l'amore
Diciamoci la verità non esiste il
coraggio senza la paura e come dire che
esiste l'amore Senza odio che visto il
bene senza il male è impossibile è vero
coraggio è e lo diceva anche il nostro
amico il vero coraggio quando la paura
non fa più paura e sembra strano però
effettivamente non è un gioco di parole
ma è così in realtà il più grande
fattore di successo per me è stata la
paura e ora voglio bene alle mie paure
ci vanno con loro ho avuto momenti della
mia vita molto difficile in cui non non
sapevo come uscirne e tentavo di fingere
che non ci fossero e Ma questo è stato
un approccio che non mi ha portato da
nessuna parte e quindi per un certo
periodo della mia vita le mie paure e
la paura che le mie idee non fossero
importanti o che non riuscissero a
portarli avanti nella mia crescita
personale mi hanno fatto vivere un
periodo molto complicato e
psicofarmaci e insomma calmanti sono
tutti strumenti che cercano di non far
Rivivere le paure Ma sono delle
illusioni mi sono resa conto sulla mia
pelle che se non cade da sola poi non
sai come rilassarti quindi
sono arrivata alla consapevolezza che
finché non comprendi e non ami le tue
paure che fanno parte di te in realtà
non habili realmente ad esperta ma se
devo pensare
che collega
Tutto ciò che mi riguarda pensa a un
oggetto che è questo a livello
comunicativo non riesco a prescindere
mai da i concetti dalle parole e un
oggetto che mi segue e che non mi ha mai
abbandonata da quando sono piccolissima
e questo è un oggetto del quale non
posso fare a meno in ogni notte in ogni
risveglio non rimpianto ogni volta che
sto cercando di trovare una soluzione
a un momento di Stasi prendo un libro e
cerco di ritrovarvi all'interno di
questo libro e
oggi è quasi coraggioso fermarsi e
leggere perché attraverso la lettura noi
scopriamo noi stessi e delle volte gli
possiamo anche rendere conto che quello
che stiamo forse non ci piace e bisogna
Secondo me avere la forza di cambiare
Beati quelli che hanno il coraggio di
alzare lo sguardo e metterti in cammino
per la semplice promessa di una stella
Susanna Tamaro e io voglio lasciarvi con
questa frase e dirvi rispetto a quello
che ho detto prima non voglio insegnare
niente Sono qui solamente per portare il
mio esempio con L'unica cosa che mi
sento di potervi dire abbiate coraggio e
in qualche modo
[Applauso]
[Musica]